you
hi everyone is Jerry let's have a look
at a game that was played at the Zurich
tournament in 1934 on the white end the
fourth world champion current world
champion Alexander le Aachen his
opponent the second world champion
Emanuel Lasker this game begins quiet
enough we have a Queens gambit declined
- where do things heat up well it's when
white is able to establish what is
really a dream home for a night so let's
see how we get to that point starts off
natural enough nothing fancy getting the
miners out getting castled I guess this
is the first thing to know roots e1 is
often seen before a bishop move there's
some tension here white wants to see a
capture so that the bishop can uh
capture on C form just one mil black
knows this and says I'm not I'm not
allowing that so I'm gonna make a useful
move c6 on board now and only after the
bishop moves do we have a capture on c4
so ok took two steps to get there black
has captured away from the center this
has created an imbalance in the center
two to one in White's favor and from
here black is a tiny bit
well white has a little bit more space
so black is now welcoming with the next
move 95 some peace exchanges the dark
square Bishop will now be gone one of
the things I questioned when preparing
for this video is would it have been
would it have been better to maybe
squeeze just a little bit more out of
this Bishop's position well what do I
mean by that I'm thinking would have
been better to play h6 and only after
the bishop moves play Knight to d5 the
answer to that is no because the bishop
can duck this exchanging it on a very
nice diagonal it avoid the dark square
bishop exchange so the very thing black
wants a dark square Bishop exchange well
you're not getting that if you try and
get in the flight square with 95 right
now there is no Bishop f4 the knight is
covering that square okay anyhow there
go the bishops the Queen and Knight now
are really well placed to support two
different pawn breaks these are one of
the two black wants to get in to strike
at this strongly placed d4 pawn okay
white doesn't want too many exchanges
wants to keep three minor pieces around
so centralizes of the night
black insists black wants one more minor
piece exchange white says no I'm gonna
keep pieces on the board keep some
dynamic possibilities in the air so at
the moment well before I share this next
line let me throw a pop quiz your way
black at this stage can play c5 or e5
which move would you play feel free to
pause the video okay well
before I share which move black played
let me just note that this here is the
worst place minor piece for white but
after the move in the game be 5 it will
soon be an absolute monster this dream
home I'm referring to for white a white
knight is f5 and for black it would be
f4 it's a wonderful square has nice
possibilities to different checks and it
always just points right at the heart of
the kingside structure now looking back
both of these hold as equal evaluation
wise I'd be leaning much more towards c5
for two reasons one you you don't allow
that night to get to f5 and two you
maintain the structure you you control
that Bishop you negate that Bishop
playing e5 extends the scope of the
bishop and gives up a wonderful square
but again it still holds it as equal
black has to be a bit more careful
though okay white gets the King tucked
away capture on d4 there's not an
immediate recapture but rather at night
now pounces f5 with tempo Queen goes
back home white now moves forward taking
with a piece with a knight not a queen
not developing a new piece white is
anticipating that this knight on f5 is
going to have some pressure on it and
wants to replace it 95 that's one of the
benefits with eliminating the d4 pawn
right got that pawn break in a capture
if a piece is recapturing this knight
the second ranked Knight can now improve
okay
this tonight is throwing a punch at the
same time so where does the bishop go
just drops back this is a beautiful
diagonal opposite the King the pawn
isn't a pin no reason to go off of that
diagonal Bishop takes Knight so a minor
piece in balance now but the knight
remains on f5 another pop quiz here what
move would you play in this position as
black feel free to pause the video okay
in the game it was Queen to b6 and this
is where black goes astray Queen b6 is
not the best move the best move is to
immediately address this fire on f5 with
g6 most common flight square is h6 but
it's extremely important black do
something about this night the Knight
has to now go to d4 or d6 and then
Queenie 7 could follow and it's just an
equal position the D file will soon be
contested with the major pieces and we
go from there it's true that with g6
there's some dark square weaknesses and
if I'm playing the black side before I'm
even reaching for that Jeep on I do a
quick scan to see does white have any
dark square bishop no white still has a
queen so there's still some care that
needs to be taken over the dark squares
but g6 is important it's much more
important to get rid of this Knight then
to not weaken your dark squares okay
well in the game
it was Queen to b6 and now this is where
white seizes the initiative starts
throwing punches where black is weak
where is black weak well on the e5
square that's a hanging piece white has
just improved a great deal with the
Queen in blacks house and where does the
knight go it's very easy to go wrong for
black here in the game
black goes to d7 one of the moves I
thought about was Knight to g6 but you
quickly realize that this pawn has now
two responsibilities one defend the
night and also defend against this
killer Knight on f5 if the knight went
back to g6 in this position there would
be Knight h6
that's a check there's some pressure
against f7 the King goes to the corner
it's already going to be game over and
if pawn takes Knight we take here this
is one of the points so initially I just
mentioned black is getting hit where
they're weakest on e5 but notice the
Queen's influence on f6 this places a
constraint on this g7 pawn what is
Knight to d7 doing its securing the f6
points so that Knight h6 is not
available
okay from here move nineteen this is
only a twenty six move game white gets
another piece involved all pieces now
playing blacks rooks have yet to
contribute till now contesting the D
file and from here Queen to g3 this
queen is now oxygen to the knight
it's going to be a big problem block was
too late to address this night g6 at
this stage where does the night go if
you'd like to go ahead pause the video
don't think for too much though here we
go
nowhere doesn't need to move this wasn't
even a threat with the Queen involved
with the night it's too much this is
pretty much the best combo in the game
Queen night combination they complement
each other very well there isn't a
threat and to me there isn't a threat
against the night and there isn't a
comfortable home for the black king you
can't go to g7 if you go here you're out
of the pin but you leave f7 a bit more
sensitive night h6 and there's pressure
here there's just never really a safe
Square for the King with the Queen and
night working together like this in
blacks house take a take a nice snapshot
of this position right here night on f5
Queen on g5 bad things are close to
happening for Team black from here King
h8 so now the night is under fire
but it jumps moves forward in hits black
where they're weak f7 is now vulnerable
King has to return and what do you do at
some stage if ever h6 then I can return
taking advantage of the pin and upon an
h6 would fall this is a this is a big
problem for team black so from here what
do we have Eve for looking to challenge
maybe the best piece best defensive
piece for black the knight on f6 'if
I've right around the corner what is
black deal runs in Reverse really wants
to scare the Queen away with f6 well
that's actually going to happen soon
enough what does white do here why did
this stage makes a rook move to pop
quizzes left in this video where does
the rook go in this position where would
you go
d2 or d3 feel free to pause the video
okay here we go
rook d3 in the game this is an
unprotected square so this is something
that would kind of run through my mind
am i secured when I make this move when
I'm trying to double on the D file or my
piece is secure if you go to d2 it's
secure if you go to d3 it's not secure
what's the difference with the rook
being on d3 well we're gonna find out
soon enough
f6 in the game last pop quiz white to
move what would you do okay in the game
we have big surprise right the white
knight revisiting this dream square with
the Czech taking advantage of this pin
the king must go to the corner and now
the final move of the game Queen takes
g6 you see the idea behind the rook
being on d3 instead of d2 lateral
movement more aggressive intentions
behind rook d3 yes it was unprotected
but there wasn't a way to take advantage
of this unprotected piece that's right
here's Queen g7 mate how do you defend
it you don't
it's matin rook f7 you just take and
well this is happening soon enough
what's the problem with pawn takes Queen
if the game continued black resigned at
this point if the game continued pawn
takes Queen rook h3 check Knight blocks
and a very nice mate all well the
remaining minor piece is working very
well with the rook on the H file so
what's the big thing that they take away
from this one a white knight loves the
f5 square and the Queen when involved
with that Knight is just a beast they've
just the synergy between the Queen and
night when they're in proximity to the
enemy King yeah it's just off the charts
anyhow as usual feel free to leave any
feedback to this video in the comment
section below hope you enjoyed it maybe
took a thing or two away from it that's
all for now take care bye
you